heavy lift but we will work with the
counties to get this done
in time for our state certification
many of these workers will be working
plenty of overtime
we have all worked hard to bring fair
and accurate counts to assure
that the will of the voters is reflected
in the final count
and that every voter will have
confidence in the outcome
wherever whether their candidate won or
lost
thank you for coming today do we have
any questions
well because we now have that verifiable
paper ballot
for the first time in 18 years we're
gonna have something to count instead of
just pressing a button and getting the
same answer
so we'll be counting every single piece
of paper
every single ballot every single
lawfully cast
legal ballot that will be
the names that are on the ballot whoever
they voted for president
the english written word
yes we will as i said people be working
lots of overtime
next coming week a lot of people be
really pleased with those paychecks if
they're getting overtime
uh that will be coming out of uh we'll
we'll determine at some point
uh adding additional workers we'll
probably have to
you know augment that and we'll be
looking at that and that'll be the
election directors that each county
will be able they'll actually handle
their own additional or their own
uh county uh recount or
wrist limiting audit county by county
yeah well that's what's really
interesting when you start really
digging into probability theorem
when you have five million votes and the
and the margin is so close
fourteen thousand if we pulled out 10
000 votes
all of a sudden they could say well this
is the person that won we pull out a
hundred thousand it says this person one
we pull out a million
this person won and that's why
mathematically you actually have to do a
full
hand by hand recount of all because the
margin is so close right now it's 14
000 101. so it's really just the
mathematics the statistics
the probability theorems that we use for
the risk limiting that are taking us to
that extent
so if it was another race or you didn't
have that uh
such a close thing then you could do
that and it would just be a sample size
but
you can't do that when it's that close
this race has national
significance national importance we get
that
we understand that we do
we follow we follow the process and we
understand the significance of this
for not just georgia but for every
single american at the end of the day
we do a hand count then we can answer
the question exactly
what was the final margin in this race
yes ma'am
well absolutely well we've been we've
been open and transparent in fact we've
had
multiple uh meetings like this meeting
with the press
uh gabriel sterling our implementation
manager has come out to talk to
really digging into the wheats if you
have any
information about illegal voting or
voter fraud
bring that to our attention we will
invest investigate every
case that we hear
uh i'm hearing that that just came out
this morning we'll look at those records
and we'll start digging into that
uh it really is what the numbers take us
to and we're following the process
that's that would drive us to that you
know that's in current state law
you're asking me to make predictions and
what we're going to deal with in facts
and so i'll report the facts
and then i'll get up my calculator and
i'll get that back to you
i can't do that off the cuff thank you
uh that's a good question but i but
after it is certified
the candidate is within half percent i
believe would still be entitled to a
recount but that would be a scan recount
just because of that is what is in state
law yes sir
uh we're going to continue to work with
the counties and all that but that's
their deadline
and that is the process that we have in
place and
we've had a great cooperation and
dedication from the county election
officials that's why we have so many
here
we have professionals out there at the
end of the day
i know that i haven't asked them but i
know that there's some folks back here
that maybe both this way and other folks
that vote way
that way and some go this way that way
on different elections at the end of the
day though
they're following a process and then
what they want is they never want you to
be able to question their integrity
and that's what we want for everyone to
understand that we're following a
process
integrity still matters
we'll continue with every county that we
have and if there's some they're still
buttoned
up then we'll roll to that hopefully
that's the smaller counties
it'll take every bit of the time that we
have left for sure
it's a big it's a big lift
we sort of our date is november 20th
uh statistically because of where we are
there
we have a team of people uh national
experts that have worked on risk
limiting audits and several other states
they're part of our team this is not
just a decision we made unilaterally
we reached out to these experts we've
been working with them for several
months
and we just follow the science of a risk
limiting audit we follow the numbers
and that's where it leads us to count
every single ballot by hand
no they're they're still required we
want them here by friday at the latest
we have 97 counties already
i'll talk to uh legal about that but we
want to start this really before the
week is up
because we understand there's an awful
lot to do yes sir
the ballot that you had uh whether it
was at absolutely ballot if you sent
that in or if it was
a voted by in person like i did we'll
look at that ballot and someone's going
to look at
who did you want and they're just going
to go through the through that and
you'll have two people that are
doing all the counting they'll put them
out and just you know in stacks and make
sure that
the stack has let's say a thousand
balance and then you look at the end
you had 501 for this person 491.99 for
that one you just keep on rolling
through and that's how it's going to be
all the way through and you're going to
tally it all up it's a big process
it'll be a methodical process it'll be
an accurate process and i'm sure
that there'll be plenty of oversight we
want to make sure that both parties have
the opportunity to observe this
because we understand the stakes are
high
i don't really know and we do what we do
in georgia we follow our laws
and every state has 50 states 50
different election laws
no that would then become uh the risk to
make on it and becomes the full recount
and that is what we're going to be
uh certifying on november 20th so thank
you very much
that'll be what we certify because
that'll be the last count and i'll be
the most accurate count
that'll be the paper ballot count
well it is actually an audit it's all in
one it's an auditory canvas and a
recount all in one because
it'll be just really a process that gets
it all
yep
well but many people don't aren't aware
of
is that where we are in the process
right now in our county
we're in the same place that florida is
north carolina and texas
the thing is in those races it's not
real close
in our in our our case there's 14 101
votes right now that separate
the top versus number two and so
therefore
the all eyes have focused on that and
that's really why you're seeing that
but the other states are still out there
tabulating their absentee ballots thank
you for bringing that up
that's still going on
the fifth district is not affected by
what we're doing here
is
well number one i am not the postmaster
general
we have no control over the federal
postal service so when people mail their
ballots back
it's then under federal government
control and the federal
you know post office uh postal service
once it gets to the
the counties then that's when the
counties you know have handled that
uh through this process uh we believe
that and we know that the machines are
correct and what you're going to find we
believe in the count as it relates to
dead people and other
you know forms of illegal voting that's
why we've asked for if you know
of a case of illegal voting or suspected
illegal voting
bring that to us antidotes and stories
doesn't work
we need something that we can actually
investigate i'm actually
very grateful that attorney general barr
i respect that man
this is the second round as being
attorney general the united states of
america
and uh he is a calm
very thorough attorney and uh
he's directed uh his u.s attorneys
to look for things the one thing that
federal government does have
is resources that we don't have and so
if they can find something that we can't
that can help to bring to bear we want
to make sure that the only people that
vote
are legal voters
yeah that we're counting what the paper
ballots are and those will be on ongoing
investigations
now we can pick whatever one we put but
we understand the national significance
of this uh session right now next time
it may be some other statewide race
uh in fact as we roll this out you have
to understand
many states that are doing wrestling to
almost it took them five to seven years
to get this going when colorado did it
that was a long multi-year process we've
passed house bill hp 316 in 2019
we stood up in spite of covet a
wristling toilet this
year and so in nine months 11 months
we're going to do the first
statewide election with a wrist limiting
audit
so this is record time that we've done
this we're actually eventually going to
be doing risk
limiting audits for a host of elections
to give you the voter confidence that
when you've cast your ballot
it was accurately counted that you have
the confidence and you can leave
at the end of the day knowing we the
system
you know got it right and then when we
do that we think it really is good for
all of the georgia
now we're doing this because it is
really what makes the most sense with
the national significance of this race
and the closeness of this race
uh we have to run a statewide audit this
is the race that makes the most sense
logically as i as i worked with our team
this is really what made the most sense
and we'll be following the process on
that
yeah it is uh we understand that uh
typically the counties fund their own
uh elections and this is part of you
know one of the things that they buy
into
and right now you know everyone's in
austerity cuts so that's the issue
but that's where we are and i don't have
an answer specific on that
uh you know i have my domain as
secretary of state
and i can only have my authority that i
have within office and
and you know we don't uh you know that
is something that would really be what
the general assembly perhaps could do to
help the counties
at the present time that would be what
it would be
yeah i think george has done a great job
if you look what we've accomplished in
this past year
we got we stood up a new voting system
new voting machines
in less than six months and that was
really because we had
an activist federal judge that said you
can't use the old dre machines
and so we had to do that for the first
primary that we had coming up all of a
sudden we got hit with covet
that started hitting in february and
then march the general assembly
had to take a hiatus around march 15th
and so then we had to
do a 360. what are a 180 on what what
are we going to do here
that we can run elections that are safe
you know for voters
and what does that look like and then
coming out of that we
stood up an absolutely ballot portal you
know so that we can have safe secure
requests for absentee ballots
that required voters to tell us your
name
day day month and year so we identify
you and then also your department of
driver's
uh you know service you know your
driver's license number so we make
make sure it truly is the voter that's
requesting this absolute about for
additional security
and then we added ballot tracks then we
added the the wait time
then we had very successful uh
early day voting we had a few lines the
first couple days and then
we had record 2.8 million voters plus
voted in early voting and we had very
short lines for that
state farm stood up but across the state
every one of these election directors
had get great success
then on the day of election we had a
average wait time in the afternoon was
about two minutes at one point my
screenshot put it out there on facebook
we had wait times the longest wait time
was 40 minutes it dropped down to 20
minutes and before no it was 10 minutes
so tremendous you know results and so
i think that we've led in so many
different areas and we've proven
that every vote counts and integrity
matters at the end of the day that's
good
well then we'll just have to continue
that process but we have our
you know our charge the november 20th is
our day
and the one thing that we've learned in
the construction industry i've been in
this thing really
hit my first construction job site when
i was about six years old
uh sitting in my dad's pickup truck and
so i say all that
i grew up with the idea of deadlines and
in our business it is all about
deadlines
and every day it's about hitting
deadlines and our election directors
they know all about deadlines because we
have this date for this this date for
that
your registration you know this early
vote day of election
and then all of a sudden you have a
runoff and then you roll into next year
we're gonna have
city and uh municipal elections and then
we're gonna roll into the next year
so this is a this whole operation is
deadline-driven
well that's why there'll be plenty of
eyeballs on them to verify that
every vote is accurately counted and
that's the way the process works
because of the large number of votes and
the closeness of the vote
it's the only way to do that we've
talked to our wrist limiting
experts in our office and also national
experts in that
we're following the process thank you
very much for coming out
we'll have another announcement later
today thank you